the major motion picture studios lost an
estimated $6.1
billion in your
[Music]
face it was well worth during prison
time for The Pirate Bay this was the
final Battle Cry of a Pirate Bay
co-founder Frederick nage after getting
raided by the police multiple times
being finded 46 million croner and being
thrown in prison alongside some of the
most vile people on Earth Frederick was
the only person in his entire prison
that was there for a virtual crime
everyone else there was convicted for
robbery assault manslaughter or worse
but things weren't too bad in prison
says Frederick he immersed himself with
reading letters from fans about how much
The Pirate Bay meant to them this isn't
to say that Frederick willingly turned
himself in though like any normal human
being he very much dreaded the idea of
going to jail and was on the run for
several years as one of the most hated
individuals by media organizations
around the world but eventually the law
did catch up with him putting him behind
bars but this only strengthened
Frederick's personal conviction as the
letters reminded him of why he did
everything in the first place unlike
other piracy website creators Frederick
wasn't trying to make money or get rich
or screw over big companies he had
founded the Pirate Bay out of principle
the idea that information culture and
the know knowledge should be shared
freely around the world without the
interference of corporate greed
bureaucracy or political influence in
fact Frederick had been fighting for
this cause long before he co-founded The
Pirate Bay or gained any sort of
notoriety before his pirate bay days
Fredrick was part of a Swedish
anti-copyright group that went around
the world engaging in piracy debates and
giving lectures about the right to
information this is where Frederick met
the other Founders godfred swaram and
Peter sun and together they would go on
to create one of the most controversial
yet legendary sites of all time so
here's how The Pirate Bay went from
being an ideological effort to becoming
an international icon despite police
raids jail time and the efforts of the
media industry at
[Music]
large the story of The Pirate Bay dates
back to the late 1970s and the early
early 1980s to the country of Sweden
where all three of our protagonists were
born not much is known about any of the
founders childhoods but from what we do
know it wasn't anything to brag about
Fredick was the oldest of the bunch
having been born on April 27th 1978 in
the city of yon chaping Sweden there's
rumors that he dropped out of high
school and it appears that he just
stumbled through his life one day at a
time a similar story could be said about
godfred as well who was the youngest of
the bunch having been born on October
17th
1984 godfred was your classic computer
nerd haacker of the 1990s and 2000s
think Dennis NRI from Jurassic Park and
then there was Peter sa who was the only
one that would be considered somewhat
Successful by modern society but this
wasn't to say that his childhood was any
better Peter was born on September 13th
1978 in udavala Sweden at first his life
wasn't all that bad his mother was a
staff consultant at a large company and
his father was a traveling mechanic but
all of this fell apart when Peter's
parents got a divorce when he was just 8
years old his mother would become
clinically delusional as she developed
psychosis which resulted in the family
constantly moving all across Scandinavia
unsurprisingly Peter would end up
dropping out of school in his teens but
there was one Saving Grace computers
computers were Peter's one and only
escape from his harsh reality and this
led to him becoming quite a skilled
programmer ironically if he had the same
childhood in modern times it's likely
that he would have become a lifeless
social media addict like my anyways
things were different back then the
people spending all of their time on
computers weren't endlessly scrolling
through Tik Tok they were enthusiasts
learning how to code and hack systems
and this would catch the attention of
German technology company Simons Simons
is the people behind many of the it
systems used at hospitals and they would
hire Peter to upgrade their patient
registration system from being
fingerprint based to being retino based
it seemed like a pretty good gig at
first glance but Peter could not stand
it at Simons after he joined he would
discover that his development efforts
were being used to identify and Deport
illegal immigrants leading them to do
Unthinkable things you see many of these
immigrants would burn their fingers on
kitchen stubs before visiting the
hospital to avoid being identified this
was actually one of the main reasons
that Simons wanted to switch to a
retinal system but this simply gave
Peter nightmares about immigrants poking
out their eyes like Victor quel he tried
to take it up with his managers but this
simply gave him the title of being
negative and difficult to work with
being drained from work every day the
only Solace Peter found was during the
evenings when he scrolled through online
forms leading him to discover the world
of
[Music]
piracy
Peter's privacy Journey started with him
swapping music and movies on invite only
servers which led him to meeting fellow
scallywag Frederick n Frederick
introduced Peter to the filesharing
movement and to the newly founded
anti-copyright organization pirat biron
or the pirate Bureau Pat biron was
founded on August 1st 2003 by a bunch of
societal outcasts just like Peter
Frederick and godfred their goal was to
make information available to people of
all background and stature and to
promote Free Speech above everything
else not saying I agree with how they
went about doing this but honestly it
does seem like their intentions were way
more pure than most of the people who
actually control the world today with
this idea in mind the group got to work
some members tried opposing Pro
copyright lobbyist groups others
traveled the world and gave lectures on
radio and the TV our Trio decided to
create a website this was specifically
Frederick's idea he wanted to create a
bit torn tracker and he would recruit
the help of Peter and godfrid for the it
and coding side of things given the
relative Simplicity of the website Peter
and godfrid had this up and running in
no time and Pat Pon would launch the
website on September 15th 2003 this was
actually just one of many websites that
this Trio launched moving into 2004
Frederick and godfred would create a
full-on internet service provider and a
web hosting company called prq don't be
fooled though this was no AT&T with prq
Frederick and godfred looked to give an
online voice to anyone and everyone
regardless of what they stood for or did
this included some unheard and repressed
voices but it also included a bunch of
creeps literally there were a bunch of
forms hosted on prq that advocated for
how should I say it unorthodox
relationships though Frederick and
godfred definitely did not agree with
everything that was hosted under
platform they defended all of their
customers equally citing freedom of
speech something else that sparked a
bunch of controversy was yet another one
of these du Ventures America's dumbest
soldiers honestly this one was quite
distasteful the website consisted of a
list of deceased American soldiers and
it prompted people to vote on how dumb
their debts were little to say this site
did not stay up for very long while
these other Adventures definitely caused
a scene by themselves it turned out that
the trios original Venture would have
the greatest scking power and luckily
for them it was pretty cheap to run
after all the Pirate Bay didn't actually
have any file hosting or server to
client downloading abilities built in
the site Simply Connected people with a
library of links and all the downloading
took place using peer-to-peer protocols
so the trio just had to ensure that they
had enough server capacity to handle all
of the search volume indexing sorting
and filtering but to their surprise it
didn't take long for this itself to
become
unmanageable as The Pirate Bay exploded
in popularity it became abundantly clear
that this could no longer be treated as
a side project so in October of 2004 the
trio would transition the site into
being a standalone nonprofit based in SE
shells though this is disputed if you
also have no idea what this place is
you're not alone the SE shells is an
East African country that's composed of
115 islands and it just so happened to
be the perfect place to set up a shell
company now they had an entity all they
needed was infrastructure enter Carl
lrom this guy was one of five heirs to
the Wasa Bread Fortune I've actually
never heard of this company but they're
super big they're extremely popular
across Scandinavia and they're actually
the largest crisp bread producer in the
world by the time Carl turned 22 this
company would be sold to a Swiss
pharmaceutical company called Sandos
which made Carl a Mega millionaire by
the time that most of us would even
graduate college Carl were to turn
around and used this wealth to fund a
variety of extreme political movements
and it wasn't long till he crossed pants
with our protagonists he would agree to
provide the Pirate Bay with all of the
required servers and infrastructure and
before you knew it the Pirate Bay would
become a fully funded Venture making
copyright holders around the world cry
but they weren wen't crying for long
they were hurt and they were hurt bad
Hollywood claims that in 2006 alone
piracy cost them $6.1 billion and the
biggest culprit enabling this asinine
Behavior was the Swedish site that was
just one Google search away the Pirate
Bay naturally Hollywood wanted Revenge
they wanted justice so they marched over
to the Swedish authorities and demanded
that the Pirate Bay be taken down as
soon as possible this was met with a
Choco from Sweden I'm not even kidding
you see Sweden is surprisingly chill
about copyright and patents in fact they
have a full-on political party called
the pirate party whose entire focus is
to reform copyright law Hollywood was
Gob smacked and they would take their
grievances to the good old us OFA surely
their hundreds of millions of lobbying
dollars would actually earn them some
respect from the American authorities
and they were right the US would turn
around and go yo Sweden you better shut
down those mischievous Rascals you got
there you don't want us to bring out the
sck and impose trade sanctions through
the World Trade Organization right and
to that Sweden would respond your wish
is our Command and they would go ahead
and raid the pirate based service in
Stockholm on May 31st 2006 there was so
much equipment that the Swedish police
would end up filling three trucks worth
of computer equipment and servers surely
this would put an end to the nonsense
they thought but um The Pirate Bay would
be back up in just 3
[Music]
[Applause]
days you're probably wondering how is
the trio able to restart the pirate base
so quickly well the answer is that the
Pirate Bay is nothing it's really just a
massive Excel sheet with a bunch of
links in fact the entirety of the Pirate
Bay can be compressed into a 90 MB zip
file so they didn't have to maintain
massive convoluted code bases and
repositories or enterprise resource
planning software all of the servers and
Equipment were simply there to support
the extraordinary traffic so as soon as
they were able to find new
infrastructure they were able to upload
their tiny zip file and go live in no
time this time they chose to put their
servers in a more discret location
somewhere in the Netherlands so that the
police couldn't just turn around and
raid them again Hollywood was triggered
Not only was the p to Bay back up and
running but the police raid had simply
drawn even more attention to the website
clearly Hollywood didn't have much power
in Sweden so they turned their focus to
American companies they might not be
able to shut down the Pirate Bay but
maybe they could prevent you from
accessing it they started working with
Google Facebook Microsoft and isbs to
suppress the sharing and searching of
pirate bail links but this only made
things worse here's the thing when you
tell people not to do something thing
that's when they want to do it and this
couldn't be truer with the Pirate Bay
just because Facebook or Google
suppressed Pirate Bay links doesn't mean
that you don't have to be a rocket
scientist to go directly to the Pirate
Bay website and search up whatever you
want and this is exactly what was
happening by 2008 The Pirate Bay became
the 97th most visited website on the
entire internet and they were even
having talks about selling the website
to Global gaming Factory xab for $8.5
million
it was becoming abundantly clear that
there was only one way to stop this
madness strike the tent on January 31st
2008 Swedish prosecutors would file
charges against godfred Frederick Peter
and Carl from the very beginning this
was a decided case Pirate Bay lawyers
tried to defend that the Pirate Bay was
simply hosting links and that it wasn't
actually encouraging or enabling piracy
if you want you could use the site to
share open source software or memes
while this was technically true I mean
let's face it these guys were literally
part of pirat biron and all of this was
completely intentional so their argument
was quickly shut down and on April 17th
2009 all four of them would be sentenced
to one year in jail along with a 30
million croner fine which is about $3.5
million they would try appealing and
this did result in shorter prison
sentences Frederick would go down to 10
months Peter would go down to8 8 months
and Carl would go down to 4 months but
the appeal also came with a larger fine
of 46 million croner or 65 million the
walls were closing in and there was only
one thing that Trio could do get on the
run if you're wanted by Hollywood at
large for causing billions of dollars
worth of lost Revenue you would think
that it would be a good idea to lay low
but all three of our protagonists would
do the exact opposite Frederick would
run away to l/ Thailand and he would
create yet another file sharing site
called Bay files in
2011 apparently this website was
supposed to comply with copyright rules
but you can take that for what you will
not only did Frederick launch another
site but he would regularly cross the
border between LA and Thailand because
he had residences in both countries in
fact he crossed the border almost 30
times before getting caught in November
of
2014 at which point he would be deported
back to Sweden where he spent 200 days
in jail at least Frederick created
another site that was legal at least on
the front godfred on the other hand
would run away to Cambodia and go fullon
spy mode and become a regular hacker for
Wikileaks he would literally infiltrate
Denmark's Social Security and driver's
licens databases I don't think that
you'd be surprised to hear that when he
was caught in August of 2012 his prison
sentence would be upped to 3 and 1/2
years but he would be let go after 3
years and finally as for Peter Well my
man straight up joined finland's pirate
party and ran for European Parliament in
the 2014 election let's just say he was
arrested a few days after the election
and he had to serve 5 months in jail by
late 2014 all three founders were not
only disconnected from their Pirate Bay
but they were all straight up in jail so
prosecutors figured that this was the
perfect time to end this once and for
all on December 9th 2014 the police
would conduct yet another raid on the
Pirate Bay and they would shut down the
original website for good surely the
founders could not pull any quick ones
this time right well they were right
none of the founders would tried to
restart the Pirate Bay after their jail
sentence Frederick would return to LA
and get a job in it Peter would work on
a micro payment system called flatter
and a messaging platform called hemless
godfried would also return to the it
sector and move on from The Pirate Bay
yes the found Founders were done and out
but there were thousands of people
wanting to carry on the Legacy remember
how we talked about it being really easy
to store the entirety of the Pirate Bay
well it turns out that a lot of people
had been regularly saving copies of the
website so whenever one version of the
website is taken down it's just a matter
of time until another one pops up with a
slightly different domain at first
prosecutors tried taking down these
websites one after another but it
quickly became evident that this was
simply a waste of time effort and
resources because the legacy of the
Pirate Bay was truly
[Music]
[Applause]
Unstoppable
Pirate Bay started off as a project
created by a bunch of Misfits and
outcasts but it quickly turned into the
icon of the internet and the worst
nightmare of copyright holders Hollywood
tried burying it shredding it and
burning it but in the end they decided
to just give it all away because what
other choice did they really have also
if you're wondering about what happened
to the Fine well here's what Peter had
to say about it during the press
conference following the verdict Peter
would hold up a sign saying that he owes
copyright holders 31 million croner and
that that confession is all that
copyright holders would ever get if that
wasn't clear enough he would go on to
clarify that he didn't have the money
and even if he did he'd rather burn
everything and not even give them the
ashes and that right there is the
legendary history of the Pirate Bay do
you guys think piracy is moral comment
that down below also drop a like if you
think that the Pirate Bay is an internet
Legend and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community to suggest
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next
one